Ви робили спроби нелегального оперетну кордону?
Ні.
Зараз у вас є непогашені бурги або проблемні кредити?
Колись із вас прибусово сцявували бурги, виконавча служба України?
Ні.
Колись ви значили з директором чи засновником якихось фірм?
Колись ви були зареєстровані як підприємець?
Ні.
Колись раніше ви робили дії, які можна назвати шахрайство?
Ви маєте якісь контакти з громадськими чи благодійними організаціями?
Ви щось об'єтнюєте з журналістами або засобовимасовими інформаціями?
У вас є друзі чи родичі в правоохоронних органах?
Ви ви готовляли в когось підроблені документи чи довідки на вашу ім'я?
На даний час хтось на вас чинить тиск?
Ні.
Ви маєте якісь зобов'язання перед третими особами, про які замовчуєте?
Ваша трудова кар'єра завжди була чесною?
Не знаю.
Ви колись мали криптовалютний гаманець?
Ви мали заробіток в інтернеті або на фрілансі?
Ви зійснювали операції з криптовалютою або цінними паперами?
Тра.
Ви отримуєте якусь частку від якихось фірм або компаній?
Ви виводили свої віртуальні гроші на банківські рахунки?
Тра.
Ви щось об'єднюєте з журналістами або засобами масової інформації?
Ні.
У вас є друзі чи родичі в правоохоронних органах?
Я показав, що нам можна робити добре.
Гуртальні гаманець, операція з криптовалютою, хамстрекомбат?
Ну може і так, і ще ж, вже тут оплуд.
Та вже просто, тепер як і на футюксах.
Та вже можна.
Ви знаєте, що таке судимість?
Та.
У вас є знайомі, які притягувались до кримінальної відповідальності?
Ви притягувались до дисциплінарної відповідальності на роботі?
Ні.
Колись до кримінальної відповідальності ви притягувались?
Ви проходили за матеріалами справи як підрозрювани?
Ні.
Ви притягувались до адміністративної відповідальності у вигляді штрафі?
У ваших родичів є судимість?
Ні.
У вас є судимість?
Ви проходили у якийсь справі як свідок?
Ні.
Ви проходили у якийсь справі як потерпілий?
Ви коли-небудь мали якісь судові розгляди, засідання?
Ні.
Ви коли-небудь допитували спірвівпітники правоохоронних органів?
У своєму житті ви робили вчинки, які можна назвати злочин?
Ні.
Ви здійсцювали злочини, за які не понесли покарання?